-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)
All right, welcome back.
Now, a lawsuit left over
from the Jim Crow era
in the Deep South
looks like it has finally
come to a conclusion.
A federal court is ordering
a Mississippi town
to fully desegregate
its schools.
This is the culmination
of a 50-year fight
against the Justice Department.
Black and white students are
largely separated in Cleveland.
Under the order,
the town's two high schools
must become one.
A school that's finally
being integrated
after 50 years?
Oh, man.
Guys, when we first
heard this story,
we were so pumped up to do this.
I mean, this is right,
like, in our wheelhouse, right?
We even wrote a sketch about it.
I get to go to a white school?
Thank you, Jesus!
No, sorry, Mike, actually,
we're not doing that.
We're not doing it, sorry.
Yeah, I know,
it's sad. It's sad.
Uh, because, uh...
something about the way
this story was being reported--
it just didn't
sit right with me.
Which brings us
to a new segment called
Hang On a Minute, News! This
Don't Feel Right in my Bones.
Ooh.
So, it felt like
the news reports were saying
that this was the case
of an all-white school
versus an all-black school
and that the town
was going to integrate
the two into one, right?
Like some sort of fantastic
racial harmony Voltron.
All right? But that's not
all that's happening here.
Let's look at the facts.
At Cleveland High School,
about half the students
are white.
Meanwhile, East Side High
School, situated
across railroad tracks
in a less-affluent section
of town, is nearly all black.
That's right: the all-black
high school is literally
on the wrong side of the tracks,
earning this week's
On the Nose award.
♪ ♪
I salute you,
East Side High School.
But, wait, if students
already integrated
the white school, why is it
being covered like this?
REPORTER: ...the Mississippi
town of Cleveland
to desegregate.
REPORTER 2: ...federal court
order to integrate.
-REPORTER 3: Desegregation plan.
-REPORTER 4: ...desegregate.
Ordering the two schools
to integrate.
-...racial desegregation.
-...ordered to desegregate.
I mean, they're making it
sound like George Wallace
giving his
inaugural address in '63.
"Segregation now, segregation
tomorrow, segregation forever!"
(babbles)
Right?
I... That's what it
felt like to me, right?
So... But the problem
is not black students
aren't being allowed
in the white school.
It's because
white students aren't
going on the other side
of the tracks
to attend the black school.
"But, Larry, how could that be?"
Well, over the last 50 years,
East Side High School--
the historically black one--
has vastly fewer resources.
Until recently, East Side
had no A.C.T. test prep,
no science textbooks
for students to take home,
and get this-- no lockers.
What kind of a school
doesn't have lockers?
Where are these kids supposed to
hang up their Tiger Beat
with Larry Wilmore
on the cover? Right?
Where's that supposed to go?
And where are they
supposed to shove the nerds?
Which, ironically,
is anyone who has a Tiger Beat
with Larry Wilmore on the cover.
All right, but here's my point:
this story is really about
the city's failure to take care
of the all-black school,
not about
the half-white school's
inability to desegregate.
That school has both
black and white students.
Call it Halle Berry High,
if you will.
Sorry, I just use any excuse
to bring up Halle Berry.
Hey, boo.
Look...
Just racially mixed, see?
It works, so...
Look, no one
wants to send their kid
to an under-performing school,
regardless of race.
So when these two schools
are so close to each other
and yet one is so dramatically
less-equipped,
it's no longer about Brown
versus the Board of Education.
It's about brown...
versus a quality education.
And that's the real story
that needs to be told here.
We'll be right back.
-♪ ♪
-(cheering, applause)